you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news live from cop26 in glasgow
today big movements in the last few
minutes as china and the united states
publish a joint declaration saying
they'll work together to ensure a
successful outcome from the cop26 summit
[Music]
two days to go but still a huge amount
to do boris johnson admits the talks are
getting tough as a draft agreement
published this morning is criticized for
not going far enough
saudi arabia denounces claims it
deliberately stalls the climate talks in
an attempt to derail them as
fabrications
we report from kenya where severe
drought in the north of the country is
putting millions of people at risk of
hunger
but in the city of chennai in india the
opposite problem a severe rainfall
continues to cause flooding
and i'm live in rio de janeiro in brazil
where we meet the man on a mission to
turn the favela where he lives green
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show live from the heart of the cop 26
summit in glasgow where boris johnson
has admitted there's still a long way to
go to bridge the gap between where we
are and where we need to be in just two
days time
and after a series of eye-catching
announcements last week the focus now is
on reaching consensus on somehow keeping
that target of 1.5 degrees of warming
within reach but a few minutes ago it
was announced that china and the united
states have released a draft declaration
on enhancing climate action this decade
so let's find out what that means our
climate change correspondent hannah
thomas peter is here with me so a joint
declaration by china and the u.s we've
heard from the chinese spokesperson so
how much do we know about this and how
much does it matter just received the
detail of this statement which is long
and detailed but i've scanned it
and this is a significant moment china
and the us saying together and we're
really listening for what the chinese
are saying about how they're going to
enhance their actions to tackle climate
change that they are going to work
together with the us to take enhanced
climate actions that raise ambition in
the 2020s in the context of the paris
agreement with the aim of keeping 1.5
degrees of warming within reach that is
really specific language and the most
heartening thing
from america's point of view and from
the planet's point of view frankly is
that china is now saying that as
necessary it will communicate or update
its 20 30 ndcs now in that cover
agreement that came out in the early
hours of the morning that we're all
digging through
the crucial paragraph that's caused a
ton of trouble is paragraph 30 and that
is a paragraph that says that all
countries must come back by the end of
next year 2022 with better homework more
ambitious carbon targets and there was
some real opposition to that from china
and russia and saudi arabia and others
and the u.s and the uk were saying it
has to stay in the text because it is
what will keep 1.5 within reach now
china has opened the door
to that being a possibility to coming
back with enhanced nationally determined
contributions that's really significant
they have also opened the door to
agreement on global carbon markets as
saying they want to work with the us on
getting that done
and very interestingly on the
transparency framework which is the part
of the paris rule book which we've been
hearing quite a lot about very technical
detail but it's been causing real
trouble
countries like china have been reluctant
to commit to filling in the same forms
as everyone else committing to
revealing targets and emissions figures
and so on so that's my first assessment
of it still reading it but a potentially
really big moment a turning point
at cop26 and we may of course get more
details from the us climate envoy who is
due to speak around now which will of
course bring everybody live when it
happens but hannah thanks very much
indeed for that instant assessment of
what's been released
well there have been other developments
here today too with boris johnson
addressing the summit as our science and
technology editor tom clark reports
the prime minister has made it clear
success in glasgow is a personal
priority but as talks enter a crucial
phase he must appeal for help from
others
it's now within reach
at cop 26 in these final days we just
need to reach out together
and grasp it and so my
question
to my fellow world leaders this
afternoon as we enter the last hours of
cop is will you help us
do that will you help us
grasp that opportunity
or will you stand in the way
so there goes boris johnson to try and
inject
some energy ambition into the talks here
the collective efforts of more than 20
000 people at this summit have been
distilled effectively into this
four-page document it's clear from the
text this won't be the summit that
solves the climate crisis
but glasgow could yet go down in history
as the place where the plan to do that
lives or dies
the text is the first in the 30-year
history of this process to call for a
phase out of coal and fossil fuel
subsidies
but it lacks strong commitments on money
for poor countries
who will be needed to help keep those
words in the agreement the historical
emissions largely came out
came out of the rich politics so the
rich politics are now asking the
vulnerable one to help them deal
tackle a problem that they largely
didn't contribute to and they have
actually been mean with cash and they're
mean with technology and so it's hard to
see how we can allow the vulnerables
contribute to help solve a problem
largely created by the rich minority
without the finance and without the
technology
phasing out oil and gas subsidies is
known to be a red line for states like
saudi arabia though they deny their
blocking progress
serious education these are
fabricated allegations
it's thought talks could progress even
against saudi's wishes
but not so china can its special envoy
accept a plan that phases out coal could
i ask about coal is the is the reference
to coal in the text of phasing out coal
is this going to be a problem for china
no country will reveal all its cards
early in the negotiations but should the
rules of normal diplomacy apply
so i'm saying to the leaders who are
here now this is on your watch
sorry
it's so important
you know
we are literally talking about
having a safe future
and you know the elders are pressing
the leaders
and understand
and this you can't negotiate with
science you can't talk about a glass
being half full
we have to get it down we have to be on
track for 1.5 and it is doable
it looks certain even at this stage
there's been progress at this summit
but success can only be measured against
the physical realities of a fast
changing climate
tom clark sky news glasgow
well let's take a look now at some of
the day's other climate news from cop 26
and from around the world and an
icelandic glacier is melting faster than
it can recover due to climate change and
just a warning that the following video
does contain some flashing images
filmed over less than six weeks this
summer the footage from the southeast of
iceland shows the startling rate at
which ice is melting experts say the
rapid rate of melting of glaciers during
the summer has significantly hampered
recovery during winter months
on transport day at cop26 some of the
world's largest car makers including
volkswagen and toyota have not backed
plans for the elimination of new car
emissions by 2040.
china the world's largest car market
also didn't sign the agreement and
neither did the second largest the u.s
but individual states including
california new york and washington have
backed the deal
and despite being declared biologically
dead in the 1950s scientists have found
sharks seals and sea horses are amongst
sea life living in the thames however
researchers from the zoological society
of london warned the river is suffering
from rising nitrate levels as a result
of sewage discharges and industrial
runoff as well as rising water
temperatures which threaten the
wildlife's future
in kenya climate change means dry spells
in parts of the country are becoming
longer and more frequent there's a
drought across much of the northern east
of the country with clean water now a
rare commodity it means millions of
people are at risk of hunger and food
prices are continuing to rise
well our correspondent ashish joshi
travelled from the river nakiria near
the town of kalakol in northern kenya to
the nasser dispensary health centre
outside the city of l'ottwa this is his
report
this is nakaria
even in this state the seasonal river is
a vital source of life
but its water is deep below the sun
hardened riverbed
bore holes dug by hand
are the only way to get to it
[Music]
digs deeper and deeper it's back
breaking work
and it's dangerous the wells can
collapse at any time
there is a drought across much of
kenya's north
here in turkana the rains have failed
again
the water table is shrinking
these water wells are the only source of
fresh water for about a hundred thousand
people and the only reason they have
water in them today is because of a
flash flood
and this is calachol town
it's entirely dependent on the water
holes
if there is no water and those wells
this that means there's no water for the
bottles and if there's no water for the
bottles there's no water for colorado
billy capu is an environmental activist
he tells me the rainy seasons were
regular but now droughts are fiercer and
longer
driven by climate change
for quite a number of years
there hasn't been a lot of rain in this
area
so that has actually
been making life quite difficult besides
food crisis there is increasing also
need for water
for the communities around
the turkana are nomadic herders
completely dependent on their animals
they used to call their country the land
of plenty
but
it's not anymore
the scrub
is burnt out
there is no grass you can see
bare and empty ground yeah
almost like those sheep are feeding on
the soil we've joined the world food
program as it reaches rural communities
hit hardest by the drought
alice is one of the young mothers who is
trying to raise a family with no water
and little to eat
the livestock starve so too do the
people malnutrition is spiking
alice tells me her four-month-old baby
joshua is always hungry
the land is dry and hot she says there
is no water and her animals are diseased
or already dead
previous droughts in this region have
been catastrophic
and they can't let it happen again
we believe that climate change is a
driver of the many issues that we we
experience here we are increasingly
seeing
the the the drunk episodes and
escalating and increasing and therefore
households do not have enough of the
supplies of milk and meat
the children here know nothing of world
leaders meeting to discuss their fate
but they do know each day brings more
hunger and more thirst and tragically
this is a crisis
not of their making
ashish joshi sky news turkana northern
kenya
chennai in india has been experiencing
severe rainfall and flooding in recent
days destroying homes and buildings the
city is frequently hit with heavy rains
this time of year but scientists say
that climate change is making extreme
weather conditions more likely and more
frequent our correspondent katharina
vitotsi is in chennai and sent this
report
if you can't save your home
at least you can try and save yourself
kartik's family evacuated on sunday
after intense rain flooded their house
how many people here you how many others
six
six people are living here
and you're staying at the school now
he tells us the water came up five foot
in here
20 centimeters of rain fell in chennai
on sunday
low-lying parts of the city are still
flooded and more rain is coming
this is the fourth day that parts of
chennai have been submerged like this
and it's not just to do with the volume
and the intensity of rain that's been
falling but also because of the way the
city has become so urbanized natural
soak aways have been built over so when
the rain falls like it has been doing
it's simply got nowhere to go
most people in this neighborhood have
already locked their doors and left but
we find one family clinging on to the
last bit of dry space they have
as the water rises around them
bringing filth with it
you can see them the
was filled by the flat
so they lost the house so they're
suffering lot of so they can't be able
to sleep here and also
how many days they can stay in the
government school
for now help is in the form of food
rations
government teams are still trying to
evacuate the most at risk
at least 10 people so far across the
state have died in these floods and
although officials say the rain so far
isn't as severe as forecast
many are still incredibly vulnerable
catherine rivertotsi sky news in chennai
india
welcome to brazil and here in rio many
of those who are most at risk from
climate change live in favelas or shanty
towns uh precariously perked on the size
of the hillsides around the city for
many there is little they can do to
protect against the impacts of global
warming but one man is trying to make a
difference i met him to find out how
in a favela north of rio i tracked down
luis casiano
hey man how are you doing
fine
welcome to my greenhouse greenhouse in a
favela come on
come on if the fight against global
warming begins at home then luis is
leading it
my friend mark very nice to meet you
after meeting his mother the climb to
the top of the house is well worth it
my green hoof
and favela happy happy happy happy
his roof garden is his pride and joy
plants of all sorts everywhere
to him the battle against climate change
is real because he's cultivating his
green roof
in the shadow of an oil refinery
[Music]
and within yards of the freight trains
that rumble by day and night
his aim is to create the greenest favela
in rio though judging by the chaotic
gray sprawl of concrete and corrugated
iron surrounding him
it is not happening fast
well
i'm have a dream
i want
very very free hoops in favela
everywhere
everywhere everywhere it's my dream
luis has an irrigation system that
sustains life above and on the
plant-strewn terrace below it is cooler
and there's a natural shower to be had
luis cassiano is a happy man
but his green dream has some way to go
[Laughter]
luis casiano there doing his bit but
anna the real story here is
deforestation and there remains huge
skepticism that the brazilian government
will stick to the pledges they are
making in glasgow
you're shipping those i didn't follow
the johnson stuff
mark thanks very much indeed so let's
discuss the day's events now in glasgow
here with me is bernice lee from chatham
house who's on the uk climate change
committee's international advisory group
and guy platinum general secretary of
the international chamber of shipping so
welcome to both of you and i'm going to
come to you in a moment because today
was all about transport here at cop so
we'll we'll discuss what you've
announced today but in the meantime
bernice i want to get up to date with
the latest on the diplomacy side of
things and get your reaction to this
news conference we've had from the
chinese spokesperson about a joint
declaration with the us what do you make
of this what's been announced and is it
a breakthrough
look it is obviously good that the 30
meetings or so that john kerry and xia
jiang hua had had is bearing some fruit
on the one side on the other hand the
joint statement which i'm the john
declaration the details are still quite
patchy at the moment doesn't really
mention finance which is pretty poor
considering these are two largest major
images in the world secondly it is also
good to see that
it is secondly it is also
a bit challenging that they haven't
really raised ambition yet even though
they're moving together which is
encouraging and last but certainly not
least it's good to see that they
mentioned methane and forest and again i
haven't started the detail because this
is so new but at the same time i'm a bit
disappointed that they didn't mention
finance and that it is possible that it
would take a while before the ratcheting
up also happened as well well yes but do
you think it could make the difference
between this summit being a success or
not after all these are the world's two
biggest polluters and the fact that they
appear to be working together in some
way
is that
the the impetus that this summit needs
i think it's a great thing to see that
they have been working together and as
in at the time of the kind of domestic
politics that we're seeing right now
moving together clearly is the only way
forward at the same time for negotiators
who have been blaming u.s china
geopolitical attention for not moving
forward fast enough they now don't have
that excuse since the two of them are
saying that they are ready to move
forward together and meanwhile we've had
the draft agreement published today the
the first text that countries will work
around and try to agree a form of words
by the end
it's been criticized as not going far
enough do you think that's fair
look i mean it is now what uh 5 6 p.m
the delegation's not going to meet now
between you know now and 7 pm they will
come back forward they can come back
with a stronger more ambitious offer at
the moment there are some good things in
there at the moment in the sense that
they mentioned fossil fuel for the first
time in paris doesn't even mention it it
talks about subsidies removal from
fossil fuels okay it obviously needs to
have more on finance especially
adaptation
i'm just sorry i'm just going to
interrupt you because i understand that
the u.s climate envoy john kerry is now
about to speak as we say this joint
declaration between china and the u.s so
there is the u.s climate environment
john kerry so let's
listen in to this news conference
as you now know
today
the united states
and china are releasing a joint
declaration
which lays out
how we will limit warming on this planet
and how
together we'll take action here at the
cup
as well as in the years to come
president biden had a conversation with
president xi a number of weeks ago
in which both of the leaders expressed
their hopes
that despite areas of real difference
and we know there are
we could cooperate on the climate crisis
now the two largest economies in the
world have agreed
to work together
to raise climate ambition
in this decisive decade
my chinese counterpart shia zimwa whom
you just heard from
he and i first talked in february
after president biden was sworn in
and our teams have worked together for
months
meeting more than 30 times both
virtually
and in person
and we have worked in good faith and we
found common ground
and we understand how important it is
that we continue that work
so tonight i am pleased to announce on
behalf of president biden and secretary
blinken
that we have agreed to a basic framework
for this cooperation going forward
our joint declaration builds on the
statement that our governments released
in april
which represented our first step
and at that time we agreed that
we agreed
on a number of actions
in order to continue discussions
to try to find a way to make progress
we also expressed a shared desire for
success at this cop
on mitigation
adaptation support
and frankly all of the key issues
which will result in the world raising
ambition
and being able to address this crisis
now with this announcement we've arrived
at a new step
a road map for our present
and future collaboration
on this issue
first
this declaration includes strong
statements about
the alarming science
the emissions gap
and the urgent need to accelerate the
action to close that gap
this is critical
we all have to be honest
both about the progress that we're
seeing and the need to do more for the
future
and we need to do it far faster in this
decisive decade why
not because
the united states or china say that we
must
but because the scientists say that we
must
the effort to reduce emissions by 45 in
this decade is a tall order
and it will require all of our nations
coming together in order to achieve it
this declaration
makes a statement about that effort to
cooperate about the imperative to
cooperate
it declares specifically and identifies
the need to accelerate the transition
to a global net zero economy
second it commits
to a series of important actions not in
the long term not way out in the future
but now
now during this decade when it's needed
and i'm pleased to announce
that we will work together
to limit methane
methane emissions a greenhouse gas up to
80 times more destructive more potent
than co2
the head of the iea has made it clear
that cutting methane emissions is the
single fastest
and most effective way
to limit warming
and that's why it's been a top priority
for president biden and many of our
partners here in glasgow
today china has committed to develop by
cop 27 next year a comprehensive and
ambitious national action plan on
methane
and it will produce a significant effect
on methane emissions control
and reductions
in this
critical decade
the statement lays out important steps
on co2
emissions as well including
the need to accelerate
using best efforts by all of us
to phase down unabated coal
in this decade
as fast as is achievable
and we agreed on the need to enforce our
respective laws on deforestation
third
together we set out our support for a
successful cop 26
including
certain elements that will promote
ambition
but let me be clear
this declaration is a step
that we can build on
in order to help close the gap you know
the expression that a journey of a
thousand miles begins with a single step
well
every step matters right now
and we have
a long journey ahead of us
so we have to mitigate faster
we have to cut methane emissions faster
we have to continue to raise ambition
and most of all we have to take action
in order to keep 1.5 degrees centigrade
alive
that is why president biden remains
committed to working with our partners
around the world
especially
those that are on the front lines
uh climate impacts the folks who are
pushing
for more ambition and more aggression in
our targets
as i think you know
we the united states support the high
ambition coalition
which thanks to president biden and
secretary blinken we have now at this
cop proudly rejoined
and as i've said many times
the united states and china have no
shortage of differences but on
on climate
cooperation is the only way to get this
job done
this is not a discretionary thing
frankly
this is science
it's math and physics that dictate the
road that we have to travel
and we cannot reach our goals unless all
of us work together
every country
and china and the united states
particularly as the two largest emitters
in the world both have to help show the
way
we need to raise ambition and we need to
take action in this decisive decade
and this document repeats that several
times over
so i look forward to stepping up our
work with china
and other nations
and make the progress that we need to
make in order to meet our
responsibility
personal responsibility and
governmental responsibility
but also
for the fundamental reason that
we have the opportunity to provide a
cleaner
safer healthier world for all of our
citizens and that is what this is really
all about
so